arturo dugane's private collection
berlin's gallery weekend provides a rare
opportunity to see it
and there's a lot of interest even
though this weekend's packed with plenty
of other art events around the city
you don't often get the opportunity to
come into this place and get shown
around personally by the collector
that's something pretty special
they have direct communication with the
artists so what we listen here is
actually stuff that we cannot really
read on the books
since 2006 this loft in a former jam
factory on the river spray has housed
atu to garnet's contemporary photography
collection
the architect has selected the works to
go with the rooms not the other way
around he tells us that right from the
start
it's a very controversial way to do it
but for me it all goes together
the artworks also have to do with the
way they're shown
the presentation of the artwork affects
your perception of it
collects exclusively landscape and
architectural photos with no people in
them
he says people would detract from the
composition
as in this picture of the cologne
cathedral by german photographer thomas
stuart
the collection also includes three works
by japanese photographer hiroshi
sugimoto
all of them hand developed
18 works are on display for the tour
almost all of them by well-known
photographers
in my case i picked the works pretty
much by myself but i'm happy to get some
positive feedback before i make the
final decision
but of course that's more risky
he and his wife are also out and about
on gallery weekend
perhaps he'll even find an artist he's
interested in buying from
dugane has known the director of the
sprut magus gallery for years and he's
interested in the works here
even if they feature too many people to
fit in with his collection
familiar with an artist and you think
sure i know that name
but in fact you only know a fraction of
their work
and it's the job of collectors and
gallery owners to make it better known
galleries appreciate when their
customers have clear concepts for their
own collections then they can help fill
in the gaps
the swisstik
for us the most important thing is to
have a genuine collector
nowadays the business is so fast-paced
and unfortunately art has become
something of a second currency with a
lot of speculation
for the artists and for us that kind of
thing is less attractive
vinegar
the next stop is the kickin gallery the
ganay wants to take a look at the
vintage photographs
there's plenty to discover and that's
what i do but there are many other
collectors who do the same and i get
there too late
as a new collector i'd rather
concentrate on contemporary works
and he knows how to show off his
collection
like this image of mars colored by
thomas woof who owns the rights
is a collector with a highly subjective
view of the art of photography
thank you for your attention
and that is what makes his collection so
exciting